hi I'm Lucy Hale and I am about to play
BuzzFeed's toughest game of would you
rather do this alright would you rather
be forced to wear wet socks for the rest
of your life oh or be allowed to wash
your hair only once a year
honestly like wearing wet socks is
pretty awful and I don't really like
washing my hair so I think I'd choose to
wash my hair for only only once a year
we get some dreadlocks going on it'd be
pretty cool would you rather have a
finger as a tongue or have tongues as
fingers I mean could my finger taste
because then it still kind of be like a
tongue or would it be like I feel well
this is like a brain okay have tongues
as fingers maybe have tongues as fingers
because then you could taste more but
then you'd taste everything you've
touched but I like tasting things so
I'll go with that okay would you rather
wear someone else's dirty underwear Hale
no or use someone else's toothbrush
honestly I'm never wearing someone
else's dirty underwear I'll use someone
else's toothbrush any day okay would you
rather [ __ ] pricks
or puke slugs I mean [ __ ] bricks
literally sounds painful
like really painful so I'm gonna go with
puke slugs because that's the better of
the two would you rather pee yourself in
public once a week or [ __ ] yourself in
private daily probably [ __ ] myself
privately daily cuz who cares probably
ultimately okay
would you rather always have to tell the
truth or always lie why is this one the
hardest for me probably always tell the
truth
actually yeah myself into so much
trouble so yeah we'll go with that we'll
be a Honest Abe would you rather never
have internet access again or never be
able to take an airplane anywhere again
probably never be able to take an
airplane anywhere again I'm cool with
that
would you rather have your body found in
a pile of sex toys or have everyone you
know see your browsing history like I'm
dead and I'm found in a pile of sex toys
I got nothing to hide people can see my
browsing history that's that's fine with
me
would you rather be in the real life
version of American Horror Story or be
in the real life version of The Walking
Dead American Horror Story probably just
because I like that that show more would
you rather only be able to whisper
everything or only be able to shout
everything would you rather run your
tongue down a New York City sidewalk or
press your tongue into a stranger's
nostril
I guess down a New York City sidewalk
would you rather find true love or when
the lottery win the lottery and that's
it
would you rather with Lucy Hale and
BuzzFeed